all right now let's turn our focus to
one of the world's greatest
photographers neil leifer
has been taking pictures of some of the
world's most famous events and people
since the 1950s the photojournalist who
grew up in a poor hard-working jewish
family in new york city
achieved a claim for his sports photos
especially those
that came out of his long relationship
with muhammad ali
lyfer is the only photographer inducted
into the international boxing
hall of fame now at age 78 he is selling
his entire collection to the brand
management company authentic brands
group
abg where we met up with lifer will
oversee and preserve his extensive and
notable archive
only on cbs this morning we talked to
lifer at this turning point in his
legendary career
neil lifer was an avid sports fan as a
kid
it became clear to me that the best
ticket in the house
was where the photographer sat for 60
years
lifers had a press pass to many of
sport's most iconic moments
photographing boxing champions you
couldn't mess with ellie he made a hero
out of everybody
racing champions secretariat i mean this
is the muhammad ali of
racing for sure and presidents it's the
only time in my life i've ever sat with
my back
to the sporting event this is where you
grew up right fourth floor
the middle two windows on the fourth
floor
lifer was raised on new york's lower
east side
where are we this is the vladic houses
they were built during world war
ii and was a low-income housing project
from here it was a short walk to henry
street settlement
which offered free classes to poor kids
in the neighborhood
and the camera club was right there you
met up on the second floor second floor
those two windows that was a dark room
the club allowed him to borrow a camera
i became the
picture editor of the school newspaper
and photographer as well
i started enjoying seeing my name under
the picture photographed by dear life
that was pretty cool
and to be honest it's 60 plus years
later
i still get excited when i see my name
under the picture
at the nfl title game at yankee stadium
in 1958
lifer caught the climactic moment when
the colts beat the giants
in sudden death it's called the greatest
game ever played december 28
1958 my 16th birthday here's the goal
line
i was exactly 10 yards in front of him
lyfer had perfect position
because he'd volunteered to take
veterans in wheelchairs to their area
just behind the end zone
you took that picture to sports
illustrated i
thought now i have a picture they might
publish was that
what essentially got you in the door no
what got me in the door was i delivered
sandwiches to stage delegation
the stage catered their closings i knew
the door
less than three years later at age 18
lifer reached an early landmark this
is your first cover well you never
forget your first cover this was
november 21st
1961 i was just thrilled if you're a
photographer
the cover is the gold medal he would
shoot over 200 covers for sports
illustrated
and time the best cover i ever shot
was a cover i did for time magazine and
bear bryant i wanted to photograph him
as though he was looking through a
chalkboard and i double exposed the
plays
my favorite covers are the ones that
came from here not accidents
yeah and that was that was it's
certainly the best one i've done
my most famous picture of muhammad ali
standing over sunday list and
didn't even make the cover of sports
illustrated didn't get a single
award how do you account for that that
picture has everything people want to
remember
about young ali as his reputation grew
the picture grew
along with him many now consider it the
greatest sports photograph
ever taken so you're right by ringside
here i am on the apron
all these guys wish they were where you
were this is being in the right seat
and then a good photographer doesn't
miss when he's in the right seat
why do you think you were successful
in my case it was pretty simple i worked
harder than anyone else i was the first
person in the stadium
i knew what time the shadow went across
the field because it might determine
what sideline i wanted to shoot on i'm
not naturally gifted and there are a
number of very good photographers
like says lifer his fellow photographer
walter eos
jr he seemed to take pictures with his
eyes closed great pictures consistently
that's really annoying it's not fair
but you obviously must have trusted your
own instincts i i knew that i was a good
photographer but i wanted to be a great
photographer this
is my newest book with an aluminum print
as its cover
it's a heavy weight on itself i am so
thrilled boxing
weighs nearly 20 pounds because it's all
boxing
it's my best pictures i hate to say
it'll be my legacy book
it includes lifer's favorite picture
where are you
that's me right there ringside hanging a
camera from the rafters of the houston
astrodome
lifer perfectly captured ali's knockout
of cleveland williams in 1966.
this is the only picture i ever took in
my life where i'm looking at it 60 years
55 years after it was taken
there is nothing i would change it's my
favorite picture
and i always will be
[Music]
it's an amazing photograph it's also the
only photograph of neil lifer's
own that he has hanging in his home
that's it yeah that's the only one
what a career what a career it's nice to
talk to people anthony who are so good
at what they do
and don't mind sharing yeah and sharing
since we've been talking about tiger
woods today
yeah who also want to share a shot neal
took of tiger woods
back in 2005 on the 16th hole at augusta
national when tango tigers sank that
amazing chip shot
that went right to the lip and dropped
in uh he won the masters of course that
year that's at the masters that's his
caddy steve williams with him there
he does capture moments i like that he
said i like seeing my name on the
photograph still i also like it he says
a good photographer gets in position and
a great one doesn't miss
yeah that's it you know that's you he
said you know i was in the big leagues i
couldn't miss
and and but it was all about for him he
did share with us
i showed a photo he actually took of uh
of princess diana's uh wedding with to
charles
and he act he was in the right position
but charles turned his head just at the
last minute he said i hate this picture
it's actually pretty beautiful but it's
like you wanted the perfection to get in
i thought too it was interesting he said
his favorite photos are the ones that
he's planned out
yeah when he said you know when it comes
from the heart i thought that was i
really liked him
and then of course and then the alley
photo the famous one of
of uh him standing over sunny liston uh
the photo doesn't change but our viewing
and understanding of the photo
and i think that's part part of why he
loves that last photograph is although
it is a picture of ali it could be of
anyone it's
it it works for any boxer you put in
there yeah the ali photograph
of him over sunny liston is very
specific to muhammad ali and that's why
people are so drawn to it muhammad ali
was
gorgeous quite a legacy gorgeous
gorgeous man he was a beautiful human
being